So Pete, I love the way breakpoints and
media queries are giving us
control over our CSS styles.
You know, you've had a lot of experience
in the past building responsive sites.
What patterns or general strategies
have you found to be the most useful?
>> You're right.
There are several great
patterns out there.
But I'll start with probably
the most simple and
one of the most important ones.
The grid fluid system,
with the grid fluid system columns end
up wrapping to the next line as the
browser width starts getting smaller.
There's a lot of good examples out there
that you can try like Bootstrap or
the 960 pixel grid layout system,
that are easy to use and
have everything done for you already.
>> Huh, well, that does sound like
a pretty nice, flexible strategy.
You know, I did a little searching,
and I found that
the HTML 5 Rocks page is an example
of a site that uses a fluid grid.
Notice how when I shrink the screen,
the articles that are three columns
across in this main section
shift down to a single column.
Also, if you're unfamiliar
with grid-based layouts, or
you think you'd have a hard
time designing one of your own,
in the Intro to HTML and
CSS course we cover grid-based layouts.
Check out the link in
the instructor notes to learn more.